More now on Donald Trump's
legal reckoning
and his reprehensible words.
The Manhattan grand jury is home
for the weekend.
The Manhattan D.A.
brings them back on Monday.
But Donald Trump is not waiting.
A week of attacks on prosecutor
Alvin Bragg
crossed into reckless incitement
after midnight.
Look at this.
It's an early morning
truth social post
from the former president
insisting
any charge in the hush money case
could unleash, quote, death
and destruction.
With me in studio
to share their reporting
and their insights CNN's Lauren Fox.
Dylan Young of The New York Times.
And NPR's Tamara Keith.
Death could unleash death
and destruction.
Catastrophic for our country.
He should know better.
This it's now been two,
three years
where we've had
law enforcement agencies across the gamut
have been warning
about the risk of political violence
and how some of the claims
from public officials,
false claims continued to motivate
some of that political violence
and make that threat more severe.
We saw similar chatter ahead of January
six online as well.
This is blatant
forecasting of potential violence here.
And we've learned
through the past couple of years
that there's
consequences to this as well.
Let me just interrupt at that point
just to bring into the conversation.
Look, Donald Trump's
not gonna listen to Hakeem Jeffries.
He's the top Democrat
in the House of Representatives.
Now, but you will get a chance to listen
to Hakeem Jeffries here. And guess what?
Most Republicans will say this publicly.
Privately, they'll tell you
they agree with just
about every word of this
Well, the twice impeached
former president's rhetoric is reckless,
reprehensible and irresponsible.
It's dangerous
and if he keeps it up,
he's going to get someone killed.
We've already seen the consequences
of incitement from the former president.
And the former president
is an active candidate
for president at the moment. Right.
And he has proven this week
by putting out a messenger
and true social,
saying he was going to be arrested
and then drawing the media
and everyone else
to talk about him
nonstop all week long,
that as a candidate for president,
and as a public figure,
he can draw people,
draw attention to himself.
And then what he does with that
attention is send out untrue, social,
racist and anti-Semitic tropes
and other dog whistles
about the prosecutor and about the case
and then he said he's not threatening
violence.
He's saying there will be violence
and that he tries to skate around it.
We can show you some other emails
he sent this week.
And some of them I just think of this.
He thinks this is helping him
emails about,
you know, other sex scandals
and other court cases
and other things like that.
He's entitled to do this if he wants.
It's a free country.
But the idea
anyway, anyway, that a former president,
United States,
would be talking about
catastrophic death, destruction,
but at the same president,
the same president
who sent a mob to the Capitol
on January 6th
and yet and yet we listen for McCain.
Jeffries
A few Republicans have said, you know,
things need to be peaceful,
but you don't hear the swift condemnation
Yeah.
I mean,
I think that one of the question marks is
if the Republican Senate was in session
today, would there be a swifter
and more robust reaction to Donald Trump?
From someone like Mitch McConnell
or John Thune? Perhaps there could be.
You know,
keep in mind that the House Republicans
are the ones on Capitol Hill today.
That is probably his most loyal
group of supporters.
And even they're not that loyal
to Donald Trump at this point.
But it's really remarkable
given the fact that
the January six committee,
they spent a year plus proving the point
that Donald Trump's
rhetoric and his message,
what he was telling his supporters,
had a direct impact
on what happened
at the Capitol on January six.
And so
it is really remarkable to sort of
be seeing this playing out once again.
But again,
there are
trials underway right now
for people who stormed the Capitol.
There are people who have gotten
you know, sentencing just today.
So this is
this is an ongoing
live issue from January 6th that now
new supporters are being told
it sends a signal.
And it'll be interesting to see how
not only you're right,
the Congress is Friday,
so you don't have people
moving about on Capitol Hill,
but the other candidates
for the Republican nomination as well,
this happened after midnight last night.
Where were they willing to go?
Because Trump is trying to bully them
into bullying the prosecutor,
if you will.
But we'll watch as it plays out.